foreign
[Music]
well hello there and what's up reaction
faction it's Deadpool don't forget to
smash that subscribe button and follow
me on patreon last week you all really
liked my Cruella trailer reaction video
where are the
this week I'll be reacting to a trailer
for a movie which I honestly thought
came out like a year ago three guy
apparently it's this August we also have
a guest reactor this week Korg who was
not my first choice but apparently
everyone else was too busy over on
Disney Plus
say hello Korg hello made of rocks thank
you for having me Paul sorry you're dead
Jesus Christ let's take a look
my name is guy oh he's named guy like
the movie's title that's pretty clever
is it
I've got a best friend this is the
greatest cup of coffee of all time
Mondays am I right yo you said it guys
let's just pause for a second and let
everyone comment first or this trailer
gives away too much or Ryan Reynolds is
just me which is super insulting by the
way all done and I work at the bank
I thought I had everything I needed but
then I met her
God I love her so much oh I hope they
don't fridge her what's fringing uh well
it's the practice of killing off or
hurting a female character in order to
motivate or torture the main character
also known as Deadpool 2. thank you for
asking ah we call that bridging
the ground everybody except you
something inside you guys they expected
you to just fall
decision more than that put these on
okay
oh my God
[Music]
what are these trick glasses or
something it's about your glasses the
glass trigger this world it's a video
game you're not real
please
and the guy responsible for this world
any thoughts on our villain cork uh
looks like he's got four arms and the
two lower ones I've got gloves on I like
them you have a Disney Plus show don't
you face oh God
trademark infringement that mean that
nothing you do matters I am sitting here
with my best friend trying to help him
get through a tough time now if that's
not real I don't know what it is I know
this world look at him go that little
blue shirt oh his face is so punchable
next guy I'm gonna be the great guy well
enjoy your lifetime supply of virginity
if you go this whole good guy routine is
ruining the game
Terminator let's take away TT he seems
quite nice actually
or grab it
maybe this is the live-action Thumper we
all haven't been waiting for
[Music]
eign
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay this looks fun in a in the last
days of fox fire sale kind of way not
sure if it was worth diverting Canadian
cumberbatch's little mind away from my
next movie or
you know what I'm gonna give it to I'll
give it four out of five avocados cork I
was raised by avocados oh my God just
kill me now
[Music]
the uh any tips on uh getting into the
MCU there cork uh have a dream uh Chase
it lose that dream just sabotage all
sorts of happiness in the pursuit of
that dream climb up to the peaks of
their mountain and when you get to the
top land at the bottom and realize
you're never gonna achieve that dream
and at that point check your emails
maybe you'll get something from your
agent saying Marvel wants to talk
yeah I prefer Dark World
half a [ __ ] penny of you for this
[Music]